the movie is set in a war torn mdova
which has left the country in Ruins
after a particularly vicious attack an
American soldier named Davis gets
separated from his team having no time
to wait for backup he Ventures into a
building alone putting on his hypers
spectral Imaging goggles nerd inside he
finds numerous lifeless bodies that
appear to be frozen upon heading deeper
he comes across a mysterious translucent
humanoid Apparition that is invisible to
the naked eye Davis transmits everything
he sees back to his base but before he
can ask for information The Apparition
passes through his body at a high speed
killing him on the spot the goggles do
nothing in the next scene we are
introduced to a researcher named Mark
kleene who works for the defense
Advanced research projects agency or D
he seems to have invented several pieces
of advanced combat equipment including
the hyperspectral Imaging goggles and
and is currently working on a new
invention a device capable of
disintegrating matter using waves Mark
presents this Innovation to senior
officials who ask him to start testing
on humans for potential military use
afterwards Mark is summoned to mdova to
review the footage captured by the
goggles that he invented later he
arrives at a US military Airbase camp in
mdova where he meets General Orland and
CIA officer Fran Madison they lead him
to the sensitive compartmented
information s facility play thinks of
dumb names they lead him to the
sensitive compartmented information
facility and show him the footage
recorded by Davis before his death after
reviewing the footage Orland informs
Mark that they've discovered several
people who have died in the same manner
over the past 3 weeks according to
autopsy reports the victims displayed
Frozen internal organs and corroded skin
France speculates that these sightings
might be local insurgents wearing
Advanced camouflage but Mark Mark
remains skeptical I'm pretty sure it's
ghosts says Mark in order to obtain
clearer images of these anomalies and
identify them Orland permits Mark and
Fran to accompany a team of Delta Force
operators into the field to capture a
better image of the apparitions Mark
mounts his enhanced hyperspectral camera
on one of the military trucks initially
the soldiers aren't happy about
replacing a machine gun with a camera
but Mark's old friend Captain Cabrera
scolds his team and recounts that Mark
is the genius behind all their Advanced
Weaponry machine gun for a camera still
sounds like a crappy deal nonetheless
later on the captain addresses his
troops regarding their mission they are
to enter a five-story abandoned building
in search of their Utah team who went
missing the previous day Cabrera also
cautions them that the area is
controlled by insurgents so they should
prepare for combat additionally he
instructs the team to neutralize any
anomalies they find there after the
briefing the Delta Force set off in
their trucks upon reaching the location
mark Fran and Captain Cabrera remain in
the truck to monitor the solders helmet
cam feeds while the rest cautiously make
their way in once inside they discover
the members of the Utah team are dead
along with the insurgents upon reaching
the fourth floor Mark senses a movement
and guides the soldiers in that
direction as they approach they come
across an upturned bathtub beneath which
they find sergeant comto from the Utah
team who is still alive comto reports
that his fellow soldiers are deceased
and their bodies are on the fifth floor
following this the soldiers go to
investigate the fifth floor where one of
them spots the same Apparition this
prompts him to open fire but The
Apparition remains unaffected and
counterattacks killing the soldier
Captain Cabrera alerts the rest of the
team who proceed cautiously to the area
only to meet the same fate at the hands
of The Apparition witnessing the
soldiers dying one after another Mark
urges Fran to order an immediate Mission
abort friend hesitates saying that they
can't return empty-handed in response
Mark claims that he can guarantee that
they're going back empty-handed anyway
after the deaths of a few more soldiers
Cabrera finally orders the team to
retreat and the soldiers use ropes to
exit through the window meanwhile Mark
gets on top of the vehicle and points
his camera towards the window where the
soldiers are being attacked it's at this
moment that he captures a clear image of
The Apparition which possesses a human
form and also has a humanlike face when
Mark conveys this information to the
captain Cabrera immediately comes out of
his vehicle and fires a rocket launcher
towards The Apparition however it has no
effect on the entity instead it
retaliates and kills the captain The
Apparition then proceeds to eliminate
the soldiers exiting the building one by
one luckily some of them including
Sergeant comto somehow managed to enter
the truck and drive away on their way
back Mark asks comto about what he
witnessed the latter explains that he
saw saw something more like a frozen
blanket that passed through his team
members and claimed their lives but
before he can divulge further
information their truck hits some
landmines causing it to overturn comto
hits his head in this accident and
unfortunately passes away everyone helps
each other exit the vehicle while Mark
focuses on retrieving his hyperspectral
camera leave it behind you nerd the
group then rushes towards an abandoned
warehouse finally they conclude that
their asants aren't insurgents as those
enti can pass through the walls and
can't be killed by their weapons now
that most of the soldiers helmet cams
are destroyed Mark uses his large camera
to focus on the streets outside the
warehouse through it they see several
specters wandering around they also
learn that these apparitions cannot pass
through the iron shavings meaning the
shavings act as a protective barrier
just then they hear some noise which
alerts them believing that they aren't
alone in the warehouse the soldiers
check the entire area only to discover a
pair of innocent siblings sari and
Bogdan hiding in a room although they
don't speak English Fran is able to
communicate with them in their language
through their conversation they learn
that the siblings are alone in the
warehouse sari explains that their
father was the one who scattered the
iron shavings to protect them before he
was killed she also believes that the
specters are lost souls trapped between
life and death Mark inquires about their
father's whereabouts and Sari leads them
to another room where she has hidden his
lifeless body from her younger brother
upon inspecting the body Mark discovers
a ceramic locket containing a secret map
of masarov a district near the river the
girl indicates that this is the place
where the specters first appeared in the
meantime the remaining soldiers make
contact with the air base and arrange a
meeting point a Plaza located half a
mile away however they're skeptical if
they can make it because there is no
cover along the way at that moment they
noticed numerous crates filled with iron
shavings within the the warehouse they
then Ed these shavings to convert their
grenades into improvised explosive
devices providing them with a Fighting
Chance in addition Mark modifies the
hyperspectral camera into a large search
light which enables the group to see the
apparitions without the need for goggles
he also sends instructions to the base
asking them to make another larger
search light amid their preparations
they hear some noise from outside Mark
uses his new search light to check
through the window only to discover that
the apparitions of found a way to cross
the barrier sensing the urgency of the
situation the team carries out the
immediate evacuation and exits the
warehouse through the back door as the
apparitions pursue them Mark aims the
search light toward them rendering them
visible to everyone the soldiers then
use their modified bullets and grenades
filled with iron shavings to slow the
specters down after a bit of a struggle
the group eventually makes it to a
rendevu point however the rescue team
has not yet arrived prompting them to
take cover in an abandoned bus to their
poor luck Mark's search light also stops
functioning leaving them vulnerable to
potential attacks before long Rescue
Tanks arrive on the scene equipped with
a large search light mounted on its top
when activated numerous specters are
seen in the surrounding buildings the
tanks open fire on these apparitions
while the soldiers in the boss hastened
to reach the safety of the tanks however
the apparitions remain unaffected by
their weaponry and start killing the
soldiers one by one they even destroy
the tanks with the search lights leaving
the soldiers with no proper Vision in
the midst of this commotion Bogdan runs
to an open area to retrieve his father's
ceramic locket seeing this sarry rushes
to his aid but before she can reach him
an apparition passes through the little
boy leading to his untimely demise Dark
Turn wasn't expecting that the specters
then gather in the center of the area to
kill the group for a moment it appears
all hope is lost but luckily a rescue
helicopter arrives just in the the neck
of time seeing the apparitions are
stopped by the airf flow from the
propeller Mark smashes the iron shavings
on the ground the wind pushes the iron
fillings towards the apparitions which
keeps them away it earns them enough
time to get on the helicopter and take
off once safely in the air they receive
word from Orland that the apparitions
have overrun their Air Base due to this
they are redirected to a civilian bunker
under the control of the allied moven
military upon their arrival sari is
attended to by a doctor due to a
shouldering injuries she sustained
during their escape sometime later
Orland also arrives at the bunker with a
handful of surviving soldiers and
supplies major sessions inquires about
their next course of action but Orland
admits to lacking a clear plan the
soldiers then begin to engage in
discussions and disputes while Mark sits
alone attempting to piece together the
puzzle in his mind shortly after Mark
interrupts them asserting that he knows
what the specters are he claims that
these apparitions are man-made entities
and are comp composed of Bose Einstein
condensate which explains their ability
to move through walls freeze people to
death and the ability to pass through
iron shavings and ceramic materials this
is the reason they couldn't penetrate
the ceramic bathtub where commstock hid
according to him the nuclear power plant
is exactly the place providing energy
for the apparitions he also believes
that plasmic discharge can tear apart
the condensate not a single soldier
understands a godamn word Mark just said
after this Mark and the other soldiers
collaboratively begin searching for
anything they can use to make special
weapons Mark turns this bunker into an
Arsenal and builds a dozen plasmic
discharge guns among the gear they
brought from the base there is also a
robot which they use to install a new
search light fortified with these new
weapons the soldiers vow to blow up the
power plant and put an end to the threat
the very next morning they set off for
the masarov power plant in their
helicopters as soon as they reached
there the first group of soldiers
descend descends from the helicopter and
prepares for the strike they activate
the robot with the search light and set
up their newly created weapon when
confronted by an approaching Spectre
they open fire and successfully take it
down confirming the efficacy of their
weapon the remaining soldiers also
descend to prepare for the impending
battle while the soldiers mount an
assault on the roof of the power plant
Mark Fran and two other soldiers Venture
into the building inside they are soon
attacked by an apparition which causes
them to separate the soldiers opt to
confront the Spectre while Mark and Fran
proceed to a laboratory a short while
later the duo comes across an iron door
and upon entering they get into the main
lab there they discovered that the
previous scientists were scanning humans
on a molecular level and using Advanced
3D printing to replicate them in
condensate form as they delve deeper
they find a number of apparitions
confined in separate cells a portion of
these cells are damaged indicating that
an accident caused a bunch of specters
to escape and the the scientists
couldn't stop them not long after Mark
and Fran figure out the emergency
shutdown procedure and start working on
it meanwhile on the rooftop the soldiers
discover that some apparitions possess
the ability to reassemble their bodies
as a result of this some soldiers fall
victim to these specters but the group
keeps fighting inside Fran figures out
that they will need to pull off all the
ports which will ultimately cut off the
energy Supply a fierce fight above
alerts the locked apparitions inciting
them to break free from their cells
while Mark carries out the shutdown
procedure France shoots the apparitions
that manage to Break Free on the roof
major sessions recharges a big plasmic
discharge gun and once it's done he
pulls the trigger its recoil bounces the
soldier off and creates a huge explosion
as a consequence all the glass cells in
the lab shatter and the apparitions make
their way out just a moment before they
can attack Mark pulls out all the ports
freezing the specters which eventually
fade away way but of course just had to
uh unplug the nuke ports to get rid of
the Bose Einstein ghosts it's simple
science following this Mark and Fran
hear a sound emanating from a room upon
checking it they are shocked to discover
real human brains and peripheral nervous
systems which are hooked up to a central
machine that keeps the apparitions alive
believing that whatever level of
Consciousness remaining is in pain Mark
unplugs the human remains from the
machine finally letting them die and in
peace now that the apparitions are all
gone the US and their movan allies
continue their efforts to regain control
of the city from the insurgence the
Department of Defense extraction team is
sent back to the power plant facility
alongside the Delta Force operators in
order to dismantle the Machinery the
movie ends as Mark bids farewell to sari
and Fran before returning to his home in
Virginia Mountain Mama subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching